Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel for the next 5 days I'm
kidnapping my wife I'm bringing her to
this remote tropical island where we're
going to be scuba diving spear fishing
eating amazing food and having a great
time and the best part is she has no
clue I've planned all of
[Music]
[Applause]
this well it is a cold wintery day here
in Alaska and I'm taking Becca out on a
date yay and because I'm a romantic I'm
Vlogging our date
we've been married we've been married
what 23 years now 22 22 I had to think
about that a little oh
yeah please press the button fore
entrance please wait take the
ticket
hi where are we going I'm sorry what was
that babe how long are where are we
going how long are we going for what
we're going on a date nor I don't have
to go through CSA to go on a date they
have a really lovely McDonald's in this
terminal I think this looks like our
gate
here are you serious what are we going
to
Hawaii I thought we were going to dinner
okay we're not coming back for 6
days do you know how I got Melanie to
agree to babysit the kids for 6 days no
she didn't want
money she wanted a
trip I told her I would pay for her to
go with you to
England you're going to have to go to
England sometime this
winter it's 5 hours 22 minutes in rout
to
Lulu
told you I was taking you out to dinner
yeah thank you well welcome to Hawaii
babe thank you I'm
excited I took the liberty of packing
for my wife and and she's anxious to get
out of her winter boots and so these are
the shoes I brought for
her I had to pack for Becca when she
wasn't looking and I only had about a 30
minute window it was a little bit of a
rush job well guys it's kind of late I
think we better get to bed I will see
you guys in the
morning well welcome to hot Lulu Becca
oh thanks all right Bea you want to go
get some breakfast get some breakfast
let's go get some breakfast
got I got my snow boots and sweater
strolling down the the sidewalk in
Hawaii I am excited to have some
Hawaiian
foodk you very
much oh that looks amazing oh fried spam
and
loo you like that bab that's a really
good breakfast burito that is really
good yeah really good H thank you very
much have a good
day jet fly
by let's go
we're headed back to the airport I don't
know
why I am still thoroughly surprised I
don't know where we're going I ladies
gentl aines now ready to flights 2454
service to M once again
Airlines
let's get our bags here you
so I might have packed a little bit more
I fear you're un estimating the
sneakiness well Becca welcome to the
island of molai yay want to try and
figure out how you got this luggage here
you want to know how I got the luggage
here I checked it on Monday that was a
layover there's there's sandals in there
and some other things hop on in baby wow
I did not see any of this C are your
feet getting a little hot yes so okay
let me get your let me get your
flip-flops out of the bag here you go
babe you like this pair right yay grass
I feel so much better than you wearing
sweaters and and winter boots is a
little bit warm in Hawaii
huh there's an axis deer just ran across
the road behind
us chicken chickens there's wild
chickens so this is Kaa kakai The main
town here in
molai well the plane ride here was a
little bit bumpy and I think Becka needs
a little pickme up to kind of fight off
the air sickness what do you
think we're going to get some of
that oh I might have to take it Melon m
yes yes you definitely need to do that
one honeydew melon Mochi there's
everything about that I love that's good
you got to try we got guavas oh Tommy
would love that light cheese
sheret that's good that is really good
thank you very much you feeling better
already it's helping it's
medicinal you like this date night baby
I love it that is really
good honeydew melon Mochi ice cream and
Ube sweet potato ice cream it is so
good try some candied
papaya we're off to a very healthy start
today
well Becca would you like to just drive
around the island and see it it's not a
big island I think we could drive around
it pretty quick
okay I'll get a loaf of banana bread all
right hey thank you very
much oh that looks lovely oh it's warm
oh apple bananas are the best bananas
ever like a little baby tiny plump and
sweet m
are those good they're so
good check it out there's a little food
stand people take the extra produce from
their trees and chickens and stuff and
they'll put it out here and it's just a
little honor System to
buy oh we got deer meat for $10 a
pound oh look at that honey that is
gorgeous honey fresh eggs oh dear jerky
lemons limes
grapefruit dried macadamia
nut all right got some deer meat and
honey hey Becca I got deer jerky oh wow
ooh it smells extra deer like I
uh that not bad there's just tons of
those little fruit stands and honor
boxes on the side of the road so I made
sure to load up on cash before coming
here
yeah look at this we have driven past so
many nice beaches and there's nobody
there I
mean look at that there's not a single
footprint on this beach
anywhere a
beach
all right this is as far east as you can
drive on the island of mikai and this is
Hala
Park look at that that's
gorgeous there's just this little river
here and if you go across it there's a
massive black sand beach that stretches
all the way over to to the other side of
that
Valley Oh
yay I think my wife's love language is
seashells I love that there's coconut
trees everywhere though I probably
shouldn't have parked underneath one in
a high wind
day well Hala Park is as far east as you
can drive on molai unfortunately the
place we're staying tonight is on the
absolute farthest West Point on
molai
oh I think that's the grocery store
let's uh we're going to try to grab some
groceries here
good here I want to do this for dinner
tomorrow I love the grocery stores in
Hawaii they have all the best Asian food
yeah red Thai curry paste miso oh M
tofu
oh we got to get we got to get the POG
yeah oh they got some
kimchi you want to do that yeah that's
like good for lunch actually yeah we're
going to get some hot
dogs purple sweet potato pancake mix I
feel like we should we should have that
just because we should have that panina
Cola coconut butter spread look at all
the different types of spam Teriyaki
spam hickory smoke spam okay yeah I got
to try those out have melon
soda oh banana
sauce all yeah all the same
[Music]
yeah we should have eaten before going
shopping I think we bought the store out
all right well we're on a date so I got
to take my lady to a restaurant here
let's let's
see
dang they've got duck poutine
[Music]
here okay
do here we go this is
nice oh this is nice you do good oh you
did so good all those pretty Windows
well we have a very early morning
tomorrow and I we won't have time to
make breakfast well I'm going to go
ahead and make some Hawaiian sweet bread
and maple spam sandwiches for tomorrow
morning that Maple spam smells amazing I
don't know how I live my life without
knowing about
[Music]
this
we've got to get up really early we're
going on a scuba diving spear fishing
charter early tomorrow morning and we
need our sleep all right I'll see you in
the
[Music]
morning well it's 5:30 in the morning
and I just made some papaya for
breakfast fresh papaya with a little bit
of yogurt whipped cream and
berri oh this looks lovely thank you
it's so
good haror looks
better all right Becca you ready to go
scuba
Diamond all
[Music]
righty a special treatment
today this is exciting oh thanks for
ring this this
cool got a nice view of the island of
Lai out
there just pulled up to this dive spot
and look at that
rainbow oh oh look at that water
Clarity all right I better get
[Music]
ready
I
[Music]
what do you think baby you have fun I
had a great time we saw lots of turtles
the cliff with the coral on it was
really cool that was great s it 420 ft
deep yeah so anyway you'll see M would
you like a Spam sandwich
which hey
TI that was great thank you so much I'm
glad you enjoyed that
[Music]
I'm
was that fun that was so fun oh I'm glad
you had fun we're going to go home and
get changed I'm a little
salty it's nice to see this place in the
daylight
oh oh those smell
amazing look leave that in I think it's
time to make some
food right we're going to cut up some of
this banana
[Music]
bread oh gorgeous here babe you want to
eat over at that table oh yeah I didn't
even notice the
[Music]
table got this some more papaya and
yogurt oh my goodness that am and I got
some banana sauce to put on the hot dogs
been a while I think banana sauce is the
best thing for hot dogs what is that
made out of water sugar and bananas it
actually is kind of similar to
ketchup that's a good hot dog this
papaya and yogurt is so good I love it
so much I love you so much I so this
juice is called pog stands for passion
orange guava and back in the days it
came in milk jugs and under the lid with
this little Round Disc called a Pog
they'd have little characters written WR
on them and you could collect them and
you play this game with them it was the
Pokémon of my
childhood leave that door unlock
too look at this right by the beach
yeah there's deer tracks all over this
beach it's sunny but I'm getting rain
Dawn there's some wild turkeys right
here in the
road if I shot a turkey with a spear gun
that'd be illegal right I
just wow we just saw more turkeys we've
seen like 20 turkeys just
today pretty rainbow over
there I think there's a lot of ice cream
flavors we still need to try what do you
think we need a scuba treat
good oh yeah that's the stuff right
there reminds me of my little Suzuki I
miss it if we're going to get a souvenir
for the kids I think this might be one
of our only
chances freeze dried Mamba and Freez
well we got to try it right look at this
oo ay
[Music]
jerky Plum lyi pineapple all right we
got some souvenirs for the boys I think
it's time for more ice cream what do you
think
I think we've done like 15 free samples
come on I'll do the PHA do to help
you this this ice cream is too good man
so so good
though word has gotten out that there's
a YouTuber on the island and we've met a
lot of people I've got a fan base in
mokai Rea I don't know about you but I'm
a little tired I'm very tired M I hate
too much ice cream it was so
good I love that the rental houses in
Hawaii have rice
[Applause]
[Music]
cookers
oh
well me and Becca got a little something
special we want to do tonight we want to
go get some hot bread yum hot bread
check it and
see bread going down dark alleys and
strange cities to find pastries
yes all
right all right I think I think this
might be it here we
go oh my
goodness hey yes oh I could have bought
you guys something ran into some uh
outdoor boys fans you guys want to eat
some bread with us come on man yeah so
we're going to need your help it's
really good that you're here to help us
bail us out of this I think we got a
mango guava and U it is so warm oh this
this might even be better than honey
butter and fresh bread we see let's see
this one's the U this is the grab an
obscene chunk here I'm going to gain so
much weight on this Trail you got to
take a mama tax there U is a purple
sweet potato and it's got cream cheese
in there
too kind like a I didn't see any bad
options on that got go grab a piece of
that it is so warm and fresh it's just
straight out of the oven oh that guava
is
good I'll tell you what if you're going
to fall off the keto wagon this is where
you
land thank you very much you're very
welcome he I got some axis deer venison
summer sausage here I'm excited to try
that thank yes like okay you know what
is in some of your old videos you were
bigger oh yeah I dropped 65 lbs uh back
in 2020 it's been nice if you're going
to sleep on the ground it helps if you
got less junk on you you know all right
you guys take care have a love happy
birthday again oh it was so fun hanging
out with that family and we are so full
of bread and jelly I have so much carbs
and sugar I love this
place all right babe let's go home yeah
I'm
tired well guys it's late and we got to
get up early for another Charter in the
morning so I'm going to put up the
camera I'll see you guys in the
[Music]
[Applause]
morning that's true I was night
great oh thank you well I hope you guys
take it as a compliment there are very
few things that can get me up at 5:00
a.m. two days in a
row woohoo oh it is a beautiful day and
it's a lot calmer so we're going to go
try the west side of
[Music]
molai where you are where there
you that's what
[Music]
serious
oh Bea did you have a good time I had a
great time what did you see oh lots of
really nice Coral some really vibrant
colors did you see the blue coral yeah I
saw the blue coral it's cool finish the
C will interrogate everybody that hot
bread stuff is just addictive put my
arms down iting behind oh we had fun we
got a little snack we're going to try
another
spot
[Music]
time to get in that turtle is
still
yeah I wouldn't shoot at him normally CU
I'd blast my spear
down I I'll get it in a
second
[Music]
woohoo look at that Becca I got a moo
it's not a huge one but it's not an
embarrassing one either
woohoo I've wanted to shoot a move for 2
years and I've come so close and failed
until today the moo are really
challenging fish they're considered one
of the smartest fish in Hawaii but
there's always a dumb one somewhere you
have a good time babe I had a great
time lots of turtles and Eagle right
there was tons of turtles weren't
there you know the bigger the boat the
more we just fill it full of garbage
was that fun that was so fun I loved it
are you exhausted
yes I think it's time for a low-key
lunch what do you think y all right
let's go get cleaned up and go have
lunch that's one thing we need is more
food
oh be is this your favorite part of the
trip so nice still so tired oh my
goodness just hanging out here on this
balcony is probably my favorite activity
so far it's so pretty would you like
some lunch I love them I'll go cook up
some
lunch got some sesame oil and ginger now
I'm going to add some black bean garlic
sauce I got this local raw honey I
bought in a roadside stand we're going
to add that to the
[Music]
sauce look how white and pure that meat
is that's so
good here you go babe that's gorgeous
oh good that's really white fish yeah it
is very
white it's not a bad way to eat a lunch
huh oh it has been lovely sitting out on
that deck but I want to do something I
think I'm going to go for a little
swim all right
baby that save me oh yeah well I'll be
back in just a little
bit hey Mana but I'm
ready well me and my friend Mana here
we're going to go to a little beach and
try to poke a
fish what what do you want to Target
today whatever you want to eat fried col
is probably one of my favorites or a
stupid fish I usually that's usually the
type of fish I shoot are the stupid
ones so me and MAA came up with a little
bit of game plan we walked up the beach
aways hopped in and then we decided that
we were going to spear fish our way with
the current down the beach and right
away we got into some fish uh Mana took
a shot at a big kumu and it tore off the
spear and got away uh I went down here
and I saw a Kala there and I knew his
girlfriend wanted a Kala so I went ahead
and grabbed this
one kala is a unicorn fish and you can
see why they call it that it's got a big
horn on his
forehead I've never eaten a CA before
but I know some people really like him
shortly after that Mana found an alua
house it's a cave underwater where a
fish called an alua or gt like to hang
out unfortunately nobody was there but
it was still cool that's pretty cool but
man that creeps me
out but Mana did manage to find a poio
which is a baby alua and he went ahead
and shot it looked like he had a pretty
good shot through the head there and the
fish tore off and started to swim off
but luckily he was kind of Dazed and so
I was able to catch up with him and put
a spear in
him and that's a
popo but we didn't have much time after
that before the sun was starting to set
and we didn't want to be in the water in
the dark so we pulled out and we had a
nice little Stringer of fish we end up
getting three of
them nice
there we go a nice little Stringer of
fish man thank you so much no
problem hey bega oh wait there's sand
all over your give me Sandy
kisses while you were gone I sat on the
lovely balcony and did a little
watercolor skch sketch so you were out
there
somewhere I'm going to take a couple of
these fish back with me to Alaska so I'm
going to scale them gut them and freeze
them
want some dinner baby
yeah B you want to put some banana sauce
on it I can try it thank you
sweetie lowkey dinner at low key the
evening it's just nice isn't it we're
tired so good it's a bit beat up now
sweet too sweet but oh that was
delicious but it is late and it's time
to go to bed we need some rest we're
tired I think it's time for
breakfast
all
righty we got a cinnamon sweet bread
here oh that is so gooey oh that smells
good oh my goodness there we go babe wow
we're going to have to go back to
healthy living soon we got to pack up on
food have you enjoyed the date babe I
loved it this is an amazing date that
bacon and eggs with banana sauce is good
that's really good I think I'm going to
miss these meals on the balcony is nice
thank you love you
B all right guys so these are Plumas
they're a tropical flowering tree and
they smell amazing it's what they make
lays out of and this whole Farm grows
Plum
maras it's nice you're
tall look at that oh oh I want I love
these like lavender and Plum areas are
the two best smelling flowers in the
world I swear this actually takes me
back when me and Becca were first
married we got really into indoor
gardening we had all these grow light
set up in our basement apartment and we
actually grew Plumas they're really easy
to grow you can just cut the branch off
stick it in a pot of soil and it'll grow
into a tree you can see that these trees
are looking a little bit ratty that's
because it's the end of the season these
trees drop their flowers and leaves in
the winter time just like ours do in the
mainland yeah you know guys being
married is so much easier than dating
when you're dating you're trying to
figure out what every woman wants when
you're married you only have to figure
out what one woman wants life gets so
much more simple and my wife she likes
Plumas I
doo you see how this tree is all
shriveled up there's an invasive Beetle
that's wiping out about half the
plumeria trees in this Orchard The
Beetles have just wiped out tons of
these trees oh that's
sad most of these plume areas are the
common yellow type but there's all sorts
of different types of colors and smells
with plumia yeah they're pretty does it
smell as
good there you
go oh those THS
hurt oh oh you did for
love do it I
suspect so I assumed we were going to
dinner so I put
on there we go
oh it's great honey scissors to clean
them up I don't know
Aloha oh that smells good which is good
cuz you know sometimes I'm not always a
peach myself so this this helps I
apologize nice it smells so good you
look good
babe is that fun babe that was so fun I
loved
it oh that was a lot of fun but it's
been interesting talking to these
business owners and locals everyone's so
welcoming and friendly but also very
apprehensive about tourists coming to
this island I've had more than one
business owner tell me they don't want
me doing shoutouts in my video in 10
years of doing YouTube videos I've never
seen that I think the best way to
describe it is people are just really
content with the way their Community is
and they don't want it to change and I
get that you know mokai really is
different than any of the other Islands
here in Hawaii they're not set up for
tourism only 7 and half thousand people
live here on molai there's only five
restaurants one Airlines to get on and
off the island and all the food and
supplies have to be barged in once a
week if even just a few hundred tourists
decided to show up out of the blue it
could cause food in the stores to
disappear off the shelves this is an
absolutely wonderful Community but even
if a small percentage of the tourists
that go to Maui diverted to mokai it
would cause chaos and because people
don't want things to change business
owners don't want me to put links in my
video description so I'm not so I think
this is one of those situations where I
hope everyone enjoys learning more about
this wonderful Community but if you want
to come to Hawaii and have a similar
experience I would suggest going to the
big island instead we did a video about
that a couple years ago and it was
wonderful and the Big Island really is
set up to handle tourists do you think
that's about right Becca yeah there's
also a lot more to do on the big island
if you want to learn more about the big
island or see any of our other trips to
Hawaii I'll put links in the video
description
below
all right got the chicken KATU got an AI
burger and a macadamia nut milk tree oh
yeah I'll I'll I'll help you out a
little bit
babe oh Becca was that good that was
really good been a while since I've had
a milkshake this one is
amazing it has been a long lovely lazy
day just eating food driving
around oh guys it's been a fun trip but
I got to pack up and we got to get
heading
[Music]
home
I made you you made it I managed it I
got through well guys we had a great
trip and hopefully you had a great time
watching this video if you want to see
more travel videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel check out our Travel and
Adventure playlist all of our travel
Adventures are there thanks for watching
and click subscribe we'll see you guys
next video If you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching